it looks like Shrek earwax I'm so scared
I'm gonna guess mystery flavor dippin
dots I'm very nervous my stomach hurts
already you know Ryan you're a nice guy
but now I just don't know it's red or
it's a pink I know that it's almost
gonna be like a cookie smell you like I
should match these up but I'm just gonna
do it
[Music]
cold wait nope I was wrong about the
wafer this is hot cheeto right a spicy
ice cream that is so weird to me it's
spicy it's not bad actually I'm lucky
gone I love hot cheetos mm-hmm okay I
just want to say that I was leaning
outside before I came in here like what
if it's some [ __ ] like wasabi dippin
dots and this [ __ ] is green a little bit
of seaweed it smells disgusting
[Music]
smells bad and I feel like that's with
peace hate you hate you this is an
abomination it's seaweed ah see here's
the thing I've been watching a lot of
great British Bake Off if you gave this
to Mary Barry and Paul Hollywood they
would say it's rubbish I'm hoping for it
to be like Nutella flavored but that's
not gonna happen and I know you Ryan I
know you got some up for me oh this
still smells like the last
[Music]
what the houses made of are you make me
like baby gnomes or something and
there's got this big old nasty long hell
is that
and what that's so disgusting
I'm calling H our free Joyce hashtag
free Joyce do you have anything else you
know we have another bite no I don't I
don't want
[Music]